Android studio 3.1 is now available for
download or update in the stable channel
along with version 3.1 of the android
plug-in for Gradle with it we've
switched to using our brand-new dax-ur
d8 for all your builds it produces on
average 10 to 15% smaller and more
optimized Dex bytecode without requiring
any changes in application code d8 also
offers faster dexing now works for
incremental builds with the sugar and
even provides a better debugging
experience when stepping through code
one thing to remember if he had
previously disabled the experimental
version of the 8 in your project by
setting the Android enabled d8 flag to
false it's time to remove this from
Gradle properties the sugaring of Java 8
language features is still done in a
separate step in this release however
you can try the experimental integrated
the sugar by setting the enable d8 the
sugar ink flag to true the core IDE is
now updated with improvements from
IntelliJ IDEA
up to the 2017 dot 3 release which
includes better control flow analysis
for collections and strings improved
null ability inference new quick fixes
and more we also simplified the build
output window when you trigger a sync or
build we now show a task 3 with
execution times and toggle an error
window in case of a failure you can
switch between the tree view and a
textural log here on the cotton in front
Android studio 3.1 no bundles the latest
plugin and supports running lint checks
for Cortland code on the command line we
plan to continue our work to make sure
we're providing first-class support for
Kotlin in our developer tools we
received a lot of feature requests for
the Android profilers that were released
in the last version of studio I'm happy
to say that based on your feedback we've
added native CPU profiling for C++ code
and the network profiler can now show
request data and has a threads timeline
and to make it easier to find the
information you need the CPU and memory
profilers now offer filtering by class
or method name if you're using the layer
inspector it's now possible to use
reference image overlays
isolate subtrees from the view hierarchy
the layer editor also got some UX polish
with new keyboard shortcuts a way to
quickly launch documentation and the new
command that lets you convert a view to
another type and just like we developed
Android Studios layout editor in step
with the constraint layout library in
this release we've taken additional care
to make the code editor work great when
you're using room databases you will now
get SQL code completion and common
actions such as renaming and find usages
work across SQL and Java or Kotlin code
the Android emulator received a lot of
updates since the last studio release
focusing on speed and stability we offer
the latest system images for API levels
26 and 27 which passed CTS tests and
include the full Play Store on the
features side the largest and my
favorite improvement is quick boot which
allows you to resume a safe emulator
session in under 6 seconds it's
completely automatic after the first
boot whenever you close the emulator a
snapshot is saved and used for
subsequent launches but in case you want
more control you can change snapshotting
behavior in the settings and even
initiate a state save at any given
moment please update to Android studio
3.1 and give it a spin and if you're
feeling adventurous I'd also like to
point out that you can try our early 3.2
canneries as always we'd love to get
your feedback on the bug tracker thanks
[Music]